yes he [ __ ] welcome to this video
I've got Mara anguish again I had a
small break their to call them there was
a disconnection wind after like a move
and ok he avoids the same thing it's
pretty rare line
I don't know he played very strange game
that came before then wonder if it does
that on purpose or really a means it it
looks like a strange opening for for
black ok ok so can I go Bishop key to
windows to lotion on I can take with a
king actually now we can actually not
take with the king there is a three ok
Bishop takes nine to five wins the Queen
and King takes as a three so and
develops so now a 3 it looks good or
then Bishop takes he's got something
he's got some minor pieces there I can
also just take and play 3m also not bad
hey three assists more powerful move now
somehow a three Bishop take the 695 it's
got tons of minor pieces that's what
irritates me okay so i have c 5 is one
thing or just take i think taking is
good I mean the night doesn't have
squares so now I guess you fall wait
this looks terrible should be just
develop come on just develop stuff yeah
he wants to go back
to be ready to play five
I just got all kinds of trickery there
check also 493 here anyway yeah
currently attacking f6 first so we take
syd Queen somewhere like Nigeria is an
issue unless that's a problem
and he's got just going to be three then
hmm
okay so if i take a check check check
nope that wasn't ideal got a ton of
pieces there a ton of pieces here just
93 i guess i will key to the ship deform
something like that
no I would do that threaten Bishop
before here or not maybe I do t6 doesn't
do much if I were just going to play
hello create that might be just sex just
push it open hand morning check thanks
at the core 97 isn't that dangerous
isn't it dangerous maybe I should have
thought there for a moment it could be
very dangerous but wow he opens this arm
I just have to check that it's it's
tough it's tough to believe
check check check you sure this hanging
check check check check check
[Music]
black4 fits on time does control over
this position or a jam every that
opening a stranger tween 85 already this
combination is a bit rare but ok
probably it cannot be totally terrible
[Music]
thing is that this has a bad reputation
that this is a good line of the news
over white so I don't really see any
other move that Knight f6 ok this one
but it looks a bit strange ok so yeah I
now just taking according to the engine
but this was a fascinating possibility
this isn't it doesn't work at all and
King takes as a 3 which is also great
him yes check so this is right and I
kept attention no I didn't keep the
tension yeah Bishop g2 was also possible
just keep it and ask him about remove
them ok so this and he can set the coin
yeah efore according to the engine maybe
it's ok i think that was quite quite
human play business for ya could use a
likes it ok this and queen to be one not
to be three yes of course going to age
seven ah this is good yes I just know
that I saw that if Sam or saying but not
at this particular moment okay I cannot
take probably can actually take
does this make sense that makes make
this less dangerous and take this and
take this and it's very good now this is
this is nothing nothing hey Laura it's a
total mess oops it's a total mess and I
now I spotted that age 7 is a problem
yeah it was just I wanted to get
activity yet or course yeah and yeah I
had the feeling that this was kind of
kind of shaky but the pollen is heaven
f5 was most keep pressing the home
button there f5 f5 was very surprising
so the engine just wants to grab this
how this is a very very tough position
of course young complete crap shoot just
look 84 and black wins look see two wins
wow what a position yeah I cannot cover
it and this is probably check this is
made check checkmate aha checkmate yeah
now I've dodged the bullet check keep
pressing yeah and blundered into that
one check check check aqua net force
made yeah I only saw the window window
material Queen a force mate gently yeah
so both sides had their chance
them just an extreme extremely an
extreme fight ok guys thanks for
watching I forgot to switch on another's
now I told you of the things cool